[Música]
comenzó en Lima la quincuagésima segunda
asamblea de la Organización de Estados
Americanos oea los temas principales de
la agenda estarán relacionados con la
lucha contra la desigualdad y la
discriminación la situación en Cuba
Nicaragua Haití y Venezuela también
tendrán peso en el encuentro Tenemos
reporte
el presidente estadounidense yo byden
visitó Florida para ver de primera mano
la devastación causada por el huracán
Ian que tocó tierra Con vientos de hasta
240 kilómetros por hora el mandatario
prometió los recursos necesarios para la
recuperación del estado que según dijo
tardará años
Panamá registró un récord en el número
de migrantes que atraviesan anualmente
la selva del Darién en lo que va de 2022
más de 158 mil personas han cruzado la
jungla fronteriza con Colombia frente a
las 133.000 registradas el año pasado
solo en el mes de octubre ya se reporta
más de siete mil
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias de
América en Francia 24 los saluda a
Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en Perú
donde tras su paso por Colombia y chile
llegó a Lima el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Anthony blinken para
participar de la asamblea general de la
Organización de Estados Americanos
durante el encuentro se abordaron
diversos temas como el combate contra el
narcotráfico la crisis migratoria
regional los derechos humanos en el
Continente la protección del medio
ambiente así como la cooperación
económica dos de los temas que captaron
la atención en esta primera jornada
fueron la situación de Derechos Humanos
en Nicaragua y la crisis múltiple en
Haití la información con nuestro
corresponsal en Lima Francisco Zacarías
con la participación de 25 cancilleres
de los 34 estados miembros se inauguró
en Perú aquí encuadécima segunda
asamblea de la Organización de Estados
Americanos se trabajarán iniciativas
relacionadas a la financiamiento de los
Derechos Humanos igualdad gobernabilidad
democrática seguridad alimentaria los
países miembros realizan un
pronunciamiento de condena al gobierno
de Nicaragua y enfatizarán lineamientos
que puedan aliviar la crisis alimentaria
en Haití el secretario general de la oea
Luis almagro destacó que el sistema
democrático es el camino para que los
países de América logren el ansiado
desarrollo sean iguales y con menos
discriminación por su parte el
presidente peruano Pedro Castillo afirmó
que la desigualdad y discriminación
empujan a la Pobreza por eso formuló un
llamado a las naciones de la región a
luchar para superar las brechas sociales
este jueves se realiza la primera sesión
plenaria de la asamblea general donde la
delegaciones presentarán sus propuestas
en paralelo los cancilleres se reunirán
con el secretario general de la oea Luis
almagro también se unirá esta cita el
secretario de estado de los Estados
Unidos Anthony blingen quien llegó a
Perú para participar en la quincuagésima
segunda sesión de la oea y también para
reunirse con el presidente Pedro
Castillo en el Palacio de Gobierno esta
será la tercera y última parada de
blingen en su gira por Sudamérica
en Estados Unidos el presidente joeyden
visitó Florida el estado más afectado
tras el paso del huracán Ian en su
visita junto al gobernador republicano y
ron de santis prometió que no dejaría
solos a los miles de afectados vayan
afirmó que el cambio climático es el
responsable de todas las tragedias
ambientales de los últimos meses en
Estados Unidos
Una pausa al menos momentánea entre
contentores políticos junto a quien
podría ser su adversario en 2024 el
gobernador ron de santis el presidente
Joe biden visitó las zonas devastadas
por el huracán Ian dejando de lado sus
diferencias con respecto al Kobe 19 el
aborto de los derechos lgbti y el cambio
climático para intentar en conjunto
contrarrestar los efectos de la tragedia
precisamente el presidente
estadounidense señaló al calentamiento
global de los últimos desastres
naturales que han afectado al país
desafortunadamente he estado en muchas
áreas de desastre en los últimos dos
meses los últimos seis meses ya sabes
más incendios en ardido
los embalses en el oeste están casi a
cero Están pasando muchas cosas y creo
que la única cosa que ha terminado es
una discusión sobre si hay o no cambio
climático y debemos hacer algo al
respecto
en un sobrevuelo en helicóptero dio
cuenta de la magnitud de los daños y
calificó la destrucción de horrorosa
prometió ayudar a los miles de afectados
de Ian que ha dejado más de 100 muertos
y millones de dólares en pérdidas
estamos pensando en ustedes y no nos
vamos a ir no nos iremos hasta que esto
termine se los prometo el gobernador de
santis por su parte aplaudió la labor de
todos los que han ayudado en la tragedia
creo que una de las cosas que están
viendo en esta respuesta es que estamos
eliminando la burocracia estamos
eliminando la burocracia Y eso es así
desde el gobierno local el gobierno
Estatal hasta el presidente Así que
apreciamos el esfuerzo del equipo
a pesar de los esfuerzos aún hay miles
sin electricidad y sin acceso a
alimentos y agua potable el propio
presidente biden reconoció que la
recuperación total del estado tomará
años
en otras noticias de Estados Unidos una
corte de apelación decidió mantener
vigente el programa de acción diferida
para los llegados en la infancia y
conocido como daca y que protege de la
deportación a más de 600.000 jóvenes que
fueron llevados al país cuando eran
menores el fallo de los jueces permite
que se tramiten las renovaciones de los
beneficios de los que ya gozan los
también llamados dreamers pero mantiene
en firme la prohibición de Nueva
solicitudes para aplicar al programa el
tribunal además envió de vuelta el caso
a una corte Federal de Texas que tendrá
que adoptar una decisión sobre daca el
presidente Joe biden se dijo
decepcionado por la decisión de la corte
de apelaciones y afirmó que ya es tiempo
para que el congreso apruebe
protecciones para los inmigrantes
cubiertos por este programa
el actor Alex Baldwin y los productores
de la película roast llegaron a un
acuerdo con la familia de la directora
de fotografía halena hutchen que murió
accidentalmente en pleno rodaje después
de que el arma que portaba el actor se
disparara en pleno set con el acuerdo se
retiraría la demanda civil en contra de
Baldwin y las grabaciones de la película
serán retomadas en enero
tras la polémica Álex Baldwin y los
productores de la película rust han
llegado a un acuerdo con la familia de
Alina hatchines la directora de
fotografía a la que la actora mató
accidentalmente de un disparo en pleno
set de rodaje nos complace anunciar la
resolución del caso civil presentado en
nombre de la familia de la directora de
fotografía Alina hutchens agradecemos a
todos los que han contribuido a la
resolución de esta Trágica y dolorosa
situación el marido de Alina Matthew
hatchins anunció que el rodaje se
reanudará en enero con los actores
originales y con él como productor
ejecutivo no tengo ningún interés en
entrar en recriminaciones o atribución
de culpas a los productores o al Señor
Baldwin todos creemos que la muerte de
Alina fue un terrible accidente Baldwin
Estaba ensayando con un arma cuando
dispara una bala que alcanzó a la
cineasta Ucrania
a pesar de que Balvin ha negado su
responsabilidad los abogados de la
familia le recriminaron no revisar si el
arma tenía munición antes de disparar
apuntar a una persona y pulsar el
gatillo
a pesar de La retirada de la demanda
civil Baldwin y otros miembros del
elenco podrían enfrentar cargos penales
todo mientras Los investigadores
intentan determinar quién cargó el arma
con munición Real vamos a Panamá porque
solo en lo que va de 2022 la cifra de
personas que atravesó la selva del
Darién fronteriza con Colombia llegó a
más de 158.000 el número sobrepasa las
133.000 registrada hacia el año pasado y
solo Durante los primeros tres días de
octubre ya se contabilizaba más de mil
migrantes los detalles con nuestro
corresponsal Óscar zulbarán
menos de dos semanas han transcurrido
desde que se igualó la cifra de récord
de migrantes que cruzaron darían en 2021
Y desde ese momento hasta ahora el
número ha aumentado en más de 25.000 es
decir alrededor de 160.000 personas han
llegado a Panamá a través de la selva
Panamá es un país de tránsito según las
autoridades mucho menos del 1% de esas
personas deciden quedarse en el país el
interés primario es llegar a los Estados
Unidos el número de venezolanos ha sido
creciente en lo que va de año pero de
acuerdo a la información que recopila
Panamá de los propios migrantes a su
llegada al istmo no vienen solo de
Venezuela vienen de Colombia Ecuador de
Perú de países donde ya habían
permanecido durante un tiempo sobre el
riesgo que enfrentan en primer lugar
exponerse a una selva virgen que no
tiene ningún tipo de condición amigable
para el tránsito de personas poner en
riesgo la salud ya sea por la picadura
de un animal o por la exigencia del
recorrido por la deshidratación a la que
se pueden someter las personas Pero hay
otros factores que también hacen aún más
peligroso este recorrido y son las
bandas criminales que operan en parte de
esta zona y que han sometido y atacado a
migrantes hasta aquí este Informativo en
francés 24 Gracias por acompañarnos
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]